الاحتجاج السلمي احد الشعارات التي رفعها
مناضلون بيئيون المان في قريه لوتسراف
التي اشترتها شركه الكهرباء راين
ويستفاليا بغرض توسيع منجم للفحم الحكومه
الالمانيه التي كانت قد اعلنت عدم نيتها
اللجوء للفحم لانتاج الكهرباء ربما خضعت
لظروف ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه بسبب الحرب في
اوكرانيا
محمد هذه اساءه هائله لا افهم لماذا يتم
تجريفه وفقا لدراسات المعهد الالماني
للابحاث الاقتصاديه لسنا بحاجه اليه
هو الزياده المحتمله لكميه التلوث التي قد
تنتج عن توسعه المنجم فالارض التي بنيت
عليها القريه غنيه بالفحم البني او
اللجنهيت وهو من اقل انواع الفحم جوده
نظرا لاحتوائه على نسبه عاليه من الرطوبه
والمواد الطياره مما يجعله اكثر تلويثا من
الفحم الاسود
لا يمكن لاحد الدخول الى البيت
يمتد على اكثر من 35 كلم مربعا وينتج 25
مليون طن من الفحم كل عام
حازم السلطات الامنيه في فضل الاحتجاجات
يعكس حاجه برلين الماس لمصدر طاقه رخيص في
خدم ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه العالميه امر
اعتبرهم مراقبون تراجعا عن استراتيجيه
الطاقه النظيفه التي رات النور ابان وجود
ميركل في سده الحكم
[تصفيق]